I could have screened the movie prom
tonight so let's talk about Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones so Game of
Thrones is a new series on HBO based off
a series of books now it's two episodes
in which ultimately comes out to like
ten minutes of watching a movie so I
can't really say if the whole thing is
good right now it's just kind of like do
I recommend it do I not and I do
recommend it when I first heard about
Game of Thrones I heard it was a new
series on HBO starring Sean Bean set
into medieval time with like a lot of
political scheming and magic so I was
just like I'm in and it pretty much is
that although there's not a lot of magic
right now don't really know if there's
ever going to be magic really but it's
like this mystical undertones I don't
expect like wizards to come out with
wands and start like blasting magic at
each other anything like that like
dragon eggs are in it are there dragons
I'm on dragons seriously throw dragons
on the screen I'm done but it does have
a lot of politics and I like medieval
politics there's like a kingdom to the
north where Sean Bean is and there's the
capital Kingdom then there's another
Kingdom where a dude sold his sister to
a bunch of like warrior guys so like the
Spartans from 300 if they were kind of
like the Persians also human versions of
Klingons there we go and he did that so
we can have an army so we can get his
kingdom back or something like that but
he's really not a good guy and then you
got this other family scheming for the
throne it just schemes apart like the
Joker said they're schemers in a game of
Thrones ah right now the only character
where I can be like that is a good guy
Sean Bean everyone else it's up in the
air at this point for most people Lena
Headey zin the show and we've all loved
her as Leonidas his wife and Sarah
Connor and the Sarah Connor Chronicles
good chick we all like Dirk but in this
one she's a dick I just want her to die
hot though be a waste but yeah she's an
[ __ ]
villainous [ __ ] from hell the things
that political epics are made from and
something I want to see more of the
White Walkers like in the beginning of
the show first 15 minutes these White
Walkers rose up and slaughtered two guys
then we haven't seen him since really
ultimately they're these medieval magic
zombie badasses who have too much spice
on Arrakis and they kill people yeah
awesome
no I like the character even if I don't
like the characters I like how they're
portrayed the actors portray him really
well you like the ones you're supposed
to like you hate the ones you're
supposed to hate and again like I've
said I like it when shows or movies will
take things to the next level I kids get
hurt and die in this show it's not like
I want to see kids get hurt or die or
anything like that but this show takes
it where it needs to go and I like that
a lot of things will be like we can't
touch children now
you have to cut that part up we have to
appeal to all of them engravings you
know not Game of Thrones so little jumpy
with the time they'll all say that like
a month will go by in the show and just
you know the snap kind of freaks you out
a bit you feel like you fell off the
time train like in Slumdog Millionaire
but the kids are like five years older
in a second and it's a rated our show by
concept and content if your parents
don't want you to see either the plot is
probably going to go over your head
anyway so you're going to hate the show
I do want to see more fighting I want to
see more battles they've said in the
show that war is coming so you know this
side is going to try to screw this side
and these people are going to try to
scheme for the throne while those people
are at war good [ __ ] but on the first
two episodes a lot of talking good
dialogue but I want more blades it's
like the Elder Scrolls meets
civilization five actually I think
that's kind of perfect so Game of
Thrones good new series already renewed
for a season two which I was really
worried about that because HBO already
had a show that was pretty much it's you
know medieval epic political scheming
show although it wasn't really medieval
it was rum and it got canceled because
it was too expensive Game of Thrones is
like half the budget of rum although it
doesn't look it so that's cool and
impressive so I'm feeling good about
getting invested into this show no sense
in getting invested into something
that's you know gonna be gone so have
you seen Game of Thrones do you like it
so far what do you think about it
comment below let me know and I put a
link for the intro to the show below
check it out it's cool looking it's a
good song it shows you where all the
kingdoms are which is really important
to know as I've watched the intro like
78 times and even now when they talk
about kingdoms I'm like where's that
oh yeah I think you have to be smarter
than me to get it all or else you're
going to be lost I still like to show
that he's a guy Thor than awesome and if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more as always click right
here to see more
you